(happy mellow dance music)
- [Host] There are 33,000
traditional temples in Thailand.
But with its majestic white exterior,
Wat Rong Khun is anything but ordinary.
Every part of Wat Rong Khun is unique.
The entrance is lined with
ghoulish traffic cones,
ghostly heads hang from
trees, and arms reach up
to meet you as you cross the bridge
to this architecturally
curious place of worship.
Wat Rong Khun's most
distinguishing feature
is its untraditional white color,
chosen by the artist to represent purity.
The sprinkling of glass
mosaics are an emblem
of enlightenment, while
the mirrors show off
Buddha's wisdom shining
through the universe.
Contrasting the white is a gold building.
The ornate restroom is
covered in gold leaf,
symbolizing the idea of the
mind's fixation on wealth
and material possessions.
(ding)
While the temple is visually stunning
and attracts thousands of
tourists from around the world,
when it was first completed,
it received negative attention.
The Thai government,
monks, and other artists
said it wasn't Thai art,
as it was a departure
from the traditional due to the symbols
embracing pop culture found
throughout the grounds.
Despite that, the
building stands defiantly
as an emblem of Thai
art for a modern world.
(sonic ding)